that's mr big and carrie bradshaw
reuniting on the set of the sex and the
city revival
i missed you i missed you
and oh how we've missed them and just
like that
chris noth who stars as mr big the
longtime lover of sarah jessica parker's
character
carrie was spotted rehearsing lines with
the leading lady
a man who finally got carried away
but not so fast the tv couple didn't
look too thrilled with each other
perhaps because well spoiler alert
according to a leaked script
mr big and kerry are reportedly going
their separate ways
but i would like to see where carrie and
big are right now i'm curious
well we'll tell you when we left them
after sex in the city 2 came out in 2010
big and carrie worked through a rough
spot in their marriage
i will never kiss another man other than
my husband i will never kiss another man
other than my husband
according to that leak script they are
now in the middle of a bitter divorce
i feel like i'm disappointing you all
the time and get this
chris says he was initially hesitant to
reprise his role in the revival
here's what he told yahoo finance in
june it was a little bit of a
sort of creative negotiation because i
didn't really feel i had anything
to offer in that role again it kind of
felt like i had done it but
michael pacquiao king is just a a
incredible writer and has
incredible creative ideas and once we
got together and talked about the
potential of what we could do with the
character i was i was all in
is that you i hope so while we don't
know what his storyline will entail
we do know that an ex from the past is
back bridgette moynihan who played mr
big's ex-wife natasha was recently
spotted filming on set
and there she was mrs big all
five foot ten of her fans will recall
that she famously played the second wife
of mr big whom he cheated on with carrie
after natasha discovered mr big's
infidelity she fell down a flight of
stairs while trying to confront carrie
and in the process chipped a tooth
carrie
i see you wait
i knew you were having an affair but not
in my house
no i'm talking to you
who else was spotted on set the kids of
sex and the city
hi hi mommy's home but you might not
recognize them because they're all grown
up
in this pit kristen davis who plays
charlotte was joined by two young women
seemingly looking like her daughters
lily and rose
this skirt is vintage what skirt it's
the cream valentino
and remember little redheaded brady
cynthia nixon's character miranda's son
with husband steve
well it looks like he's all grown up too
[Music]
the highly anticipated sex and the city
revival on hbo max
doesn't have a release date yet but we
can't wait to see how this next chapter
plays out
you